you
he died in 18-49 aged 63 he was one of
the important ones now we know nothing
of him see if his name dust to dust
it sounds peculiar to want to come out
here to the old graveyard and the rent
church for no motive other than to take
in the philosophy that emanates from
them how much these places have to teach
us nothing can water quite so much when
this is what all achievement elementa
the can be no protection from this fate
once people sat in pews here they were
proud of their new Hut or fine gloves
they are nodded to their neighbors and
whispered the occasional rumor they
discreetly scratched their legs they
examined their consciences some felt
deeply sorry for the wrongs they knew
they had done others know the
institution and not just this particular
building is in rooms they were trying
hard of course they try to make death
less terrifying they invented rituals to
bring consolation and dignity to grief
they used soul
laughs the mysterious species stand
glass they invented powerful magical
stories which said that dying was only a
transition to another more real
existence but there was a God who would
show us mercy they wanted to remind us
that loss is universal inevitable and
not the end
but the sorrow we feel though
heartbreaking is part of the plan
we don't want to go back to those old
beliefs and anywhere we kept but they
didn't get everything the churchyard
whispers to us about the shortness of
our days these people were just like us
then it was over as it will be for us
too for long life is at best
five hundred thousand hours of
consciousness many of which are behind
us already this haunting place urges us
with melancholy poetry to alter our
lives and our priorities while a little
time still remains to us
you